so restoring com is our media task but
over the longer term we have to do more
than just lower tensions
the United States is committed to
working toward our enduring goal of
ensuring that Palestinians and Israelis
enjoy equal measures of Freedom security
opportunity Justice and dignity
and it's President Biden's firm
conviction that the only way to achieve
that goal is through preserving and then
realizing the vision of two states for
two peoples
the United States will continue to
oppose anything that puts that goal
further from reach including but not
limited to settlement expansion
legalization of illegal outposts move
towards annexation of the West Bank
disruption to the historic status quo on
Jerusalem's holy sites demolitions and
evictions and incitement and
acquiescence to violence
we will also support all efforts to move
us closer to peace
expand a horizon of Hope
Advance equal rights and opportunities
for Palestinians and Israelis
that includes building on the efforts
that we made over the past two years to
improve the lives of the Palestinian
people in concrete ways
we bolstered our assistance to the
United Nations relief and works Agency
for Palestinian refugees anra including
approximately 50 million dollars in new
funding that I announced today in
Ramallah enabling the provision of
essential services like food vaccines
education as well as vital aid for
refugees
that brings U.S total funding for
Palestinians over the last two years to
nearly 940 million dollars
we're supporting Quality Health Care
through these Jerusalem Hospital Network
and we're making real progress toward
implementing an agreement to provide a
4G network in the Palestinian
territories